excusé aujourd'hui je suis pas excité
parce qu'on va jouer à emilie the way
you make on sépare milliards 2 millions
de milliers parce qu'il est hyper
original apparemment on va parler à
travers une sorte de msn a une femme et
il faut la pêche au chapitre 1 en 2002
c'est parti on faisait voir en tchat
et à chaque fois on a trois propositions
de réponses au caniche est un nom de
famille tout doux hämmerli 35 a signalé
mme merli 35 c'est emilie donc la crise
connais on dit hey
moi j'aime bien l'oreille et l'envoyer
pour moi qui écris ça vexe
automatiquement placé début d'une grande
histoire c'est le début d'une grande
histoire elle m'a dit bonjour en réponse
pékin
on va aller loin alors comment ça va je
te parle donc ça va voilà l élantra
d'écouter de la musique et me demande si
j'aime code colplay hommage adore
j'adore emilie je sais pas ce que tu
m'intéresses plus tard je suis très
content que tu les aimes c'est mon
groupe préféré
est ce que tu vas à la soirée chez
travis ce soir au plus tard alors je
peux dire peut-être je me sens pas
décidé ouais mais travis et une bite ou
sa dépense suivant aux allées pour
situer va c'est pas mal ça s'est un peu
canard mais c'est pas mal
il faut toucher de montrer son
intéressement lol ouais j'y serai donc
tu devrais y aller où
j'hésite à dire que la vie c'est une
merde comme ça ça ça éloigne tout de
suite et munis d'autres devises ou est
ce que je veux dire travailler c'est une
grosse merde lol généralement explosé
derrière tu sais bracket avec nous en
cours de maths il arrête pas m'envoyer
des messages au nom tâche pas dit que là
je pas dit que par les moyens
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire ignore le
ignore le voilà c'est mon plan mais là
pas dire qu'il veut qu'on parlât ne lui
parle pas aux mecs on à un mois de la
reprise des diplômes on est tellement
vieux est ce que tu as déjà choisi ton
école c'est sur apb 1a on connaît bien
tout ça j'ai pas été accepté dans
l'école que je voulais au nom et toi tu
vas ou une école d'art nous on est
mystérieux où les artistes dans l'âme
ça va l'intrigué à vouloir se renseigner
se dire où il est atypique tout jeune
homme c'est bien une école d'art cheval
vraiment sûr de ce que je veux faire là
bas mais je suis sûr que je me
débrouillerai oui c'est bien ça c'est
cool tu as toujours été très talentueux
c'est bien ça avant qu'on a chacun dans
une différentes écoles tu me promets que
tu seras toujours là pour moi j'ai pas
envie d absolument parce qu'après on est
trois à ses pieds vous voyez il faut
plus faut pas qu'elles croient qu'on
détroit de bétail les meufs qui
regardent les vidéos elles donnent
tellement se taper des barres il faut
pas qu'on soit totalement à ses pieds
voyez ce que je veux dire donc on va
dire je ferai de mon mieux mais
attention à toi ô il est à j'espère que
julie sera là bientôt comme ça on pourra
aller à la fête ensemble ouais mais si
je dit julie qui ça veut dire que je
m'intéresse à une autre fille s'est pas
très bien
ouais mais j'ai envie de savoir quand
même si c'est l'autre fille attention
petit technique si vous avez eu pécho
une fille fait sûrs en sorte que sa
meilleure amie vous adore ça marche très
bien
certes on peut juste ça mes amis c'est
pour ça que je demande
julie miller elle est en cours de maths
avec nous une fois qu'elle serait si on
aura tous les deux à la fête de travis
si tu viens aussi tu devrais bientôt
partir est-ce que je te verrai la ba oui
allez allez allez super je me prépare et
je vais attendre julie j'espère que brad
arrêtera de m'envoyer des messages que
je remets comportement silencieux hockey
de classer les chapitres qui vient de
terminer et là on passe à 2003 on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé lors de cette
soirée j'espère qu'on va la prendre
j'espère qu'il a réussi à faire un petit
truc tout doux et what's up
comment ça va je vais devoir j'écoute de
la musique et toi je mets de voir où
jouent aux jeux vidéo alors je vais
devoir le devoir comme ça on est un
petit peu studio et tous ces parfaits
quelle musique était en train d'écouter
coldplay non snow patrol
ils ont sorti leur nouvel album found
love trop est-ce que tu l'as entendu
ouais j'ai entendu c'est super c'est
faux c'est totalement faux mais ouf on
fait semblant d'aimer les mêmes choses
qu'elle omer foot est toujours au
courant des meilleurs sons je sais bien
je sais bien quelle est ta chanson
préférée sur cet album
google la guilde et trois bons et une au
pif un club tu croques c'est pas mal
est-ce que sa préférée aussi aller non
watts ce n'est pas une chanson sur cet
album
peut-être qu'on parlait pas de la même
chose alors est ce qu est un train
d'apprécier ton et kolda ouais c'est pas
fun mais non mais qu'est ce qui dit il
dit qu'il a eu de la chance et qui a eu
des gens super cool dans sa classe les
bakwa can feel que tard péter tout
s'écoule moi ma classe alors nommé yang
faudrait que je te voir un de ces quatre
est ce que tu fais quelque chose ce soir
ouais je dois aller je fais une super
fête avec mes amis et j'espère qu'elle
va venir au salaire fun ne bois pas trop
ne t'en fais pas je ferai attention tu
fais quelque chose ce soir
asselah qui va l'inviter c'est bon c'est
pas trompé nombre à l'entraînement donc
je vais juste rennais dans mon dortoir
quoi en ont c'est pas devenu son mec
le cdh mais qu'il harcelait aux sms et
ce que je connais brad doigts et nos
bras non ne dis pas que c'est lui et la
force et s'est passé brad c'est mon
copain tu te souviens de lui de l'école
la dernière n'est ce pas
on est ensemble depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant
je crois que c'est un début de chagrin
d'amour oui je sais c'est la bo va ou à
pois et postée au cool
comment vous avez fini ensemble tous les
deux aulas est l'écrin de ces pavés
souvient cette fête à laquelle on est
allé l'année dernière pendant que
j'étais pas là brown envoyé des tonnes
de messages m'expliquant ce qu'il
ressentait pour moi au début j'ai pensé
que c'était très bizarre mais après un
moment j'ai réalisé que c'était super
braves de sa part on a commencé à se
réparer l'été dernier on a réalisé qu'on
allait à la même école putain email sur
l'école mais tout de suite on demande si
l amour au scrutin la part payée par
quatre chemins au jeu c'est pas l'aimer
est un grand mot c'est bon ça et parfois
ça peut être un connard mais qu'on se
comporte bien c'est super cool un
connard en mode qu'est ce qu'il a fait
on valoir on sait ce master de brad
je veux dire qu'on n'est pas toujours du
même avis et comme on est tous les deux
des têtes de mule les bains sommes
partis en steak mais comme j'ai dit
quelque chose se passe bien c'est
vraiment super honnêtement et milices et
ressemble à une mauvaise relation
j'espère qu'il ya pas mal le prendre
pitié mais les fais pas ta pute je pense
que c'est juste une relation normale
tous les couples sans bruit un peu ok ça
juste que je tiens vraiment non non il
avait créé un truc cool
il avait dit ok ça juste que je tiens
vraiment beaucoup à toi et là il effacer
les marques
ok ça juste qu'il ya des gens qui
tiennent vraiment à toi et coup je pense
que tout va bien je veux plus parler de
ça o le stop qu'on s'est pris mon gars
en est à 100 sous l'autoroute on s'est
pris un stop comme ça comme ça on va
dire désolant devrait s'excuser c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu forcé la main on a
un peu forcé désolé je veux juste que tu
sois tu dois aller à cette fête n'est ce
pas veut dire je peux rester voilà comme
ça je reste et je ne parle pas assez
cool de ta part mais je veux pas que tu
rates quoi que ce soit je t'attendrai
maintenant et on peut que répondre voire
butin assez nul on a tout raté mon gars
on a été nul à chier
ml et comment ça va loin se passe ta vie
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'a pas parlé
depuis un moment on s'éclaire bezeq
maviel ennuyante comme ça nous a
peut-être qu'on soit pour me remonter le
moral elle tout va bien elle me demande
si j'ai des plans ce week-end au hp dave
à un spectacle et je veux l'emmener et
voilà ce qu'on lui dit qu'il va
inspecter grec sésame il fallait pas
dire ça alan hely dont il va pas
s'attaquer avec des amis il veut un
spectacle avec son ami qui s'appelle et
maquiller et m'a alors attendez la
latence sur l'instant l'instant analyse
emilie c'est une fille qui sait qu'on
est carrément à ses pieds et si on lui
dit qu'il ya une ou deux filles dans
notre vie que elle elle va peut-être
tilt et qu'elle tient vraiment à nous
beaucoup plus qu'elle ne le pensait et
elle va avoir peur de nous perdre on va
dire c'est juste une fille voilà pas une
fille qu'on aime beaucoup le pensent pas
avoir entendu parler d'elle avant
comment vous êtes rencontrés
bon on va dire que c'est mike qui nous a
introduit donc tu l'as précis je vais
dire je sais pas comme ça elle a des
doutes et mini c'est pas mal ce qu'on
fait c'est pas mal
wahou tout doux on dirait que tout va
très bien pour toi c'est super cool on
va s'intéresser à elle lui demander si
tout va bien et ensuite qu'on m'avait
demandé de se voir ce soir elle va mal
everything kind of sex
je suis désolé m'a dit je suis désolée à
faire le genre c'est tellement triste
elle dit qu'elle va bien mais c'est très
bizarre depuis que elle et lui avaient
le même groupe d'amis donc les choses
sont bizarres je me sens vraiment seul
tu vois il faut qu'on la voir il faut
qu'on la voir je comprends totalement
comment tu te sens même proposé de se
voir pitié je vais demander pourquoi ils
sont séparés
brown a beaucoup changé pendant l'été et
à notre tour les choses étaient très
différents un mec je commence à pleurer
il n'en vaut pas la peine tu es une
personne incroyable c'est bien ça c'est
bien merci je suis désolé d'être un tel
gâchis mais non mais arrête arrête tu es
très bien merci c'est cool d'être
capable de parler de ça avec toi je
n'avais pas eu la chance d'en parler
avant je sais que je fais pareil c'est
bien ça je veux te demander quelque
chose mais j'ai peur que tu me détestes
après quoi tout simplement la question à
la fête de travis l'année dernière tu te
souviens qu'on était saoulé et qu'on est
parti marcher on s'est arrêté dans cette
aire de jeu pour un moment on s'est
juste posé la regarder les étoiles
pourquoi tu ne m'as pas embrasser quoi
il apprendre à s'aimer fois que je vous
disais quand vous êtes sur une fille
pour trait lui sinon elle va vous
prendrez vous mettre dans la boîte amis
voilà pour toujours pour la vie au
revoir c'est bien je savais pas que je
ressentais ça c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal je me suis juste pour
demander comment les choses se seraient
passées si tu m'avais embrasser jour là
on va dire j'aimerais avoir embrassé ce
jour là et j'ai une idée au peut-être
qu'on pourrait se voir ce week-end
on s'est toujours dit qu'on devrait se
voir l'un et l'autre qu'est ce que tu en
penses
obama s'il te plait bien boire direct
trop cool je suis super excité c'est ça
ml ouailles à propos de ce que tu avais
prévu avec emma putain heureusement
juridique et moi j'étais sur l instant
j'étais foutu je les classe et tout est
là pas faire chier à ok juste pas te
mettre dans la merde qu'est ce que tu
veux faire ce week-end
on se retrouve dans ma chambre on va
faire la fête ou on fait des choses
autour du campus va faire des trucs
autour du campus c'est pas mal parce que
si on va des flèches quel récipient
content de rencontrer d'autres hommes
ça a l'air cool yes est ce que je dors
amener d'alcool oula oula oula et je
peux répondre ouais vas y ramène j'en ai
où on n'en a pas besoin
on n'a pas besoin en a pas besoin ok je
suis très excité de finalement venir te
voir au maire je dois y aller mais on
reçoit ce week-end au quai bien sûr
oh là là et là ça va être le dernier
chapitre on va savoir la main histoire
putain on va découvrir ce qui s'est
passé ce putain de week end
ce putain de week end ok je suis très
excité de finalement venir te voir
pourquoi tu ne m'as pas embrasser ma tu
ne m'as pas embrassés nous ne pouvons
pas savoir ce qui s'est passé lors de ce
week end nous le sommes bien évidemment
dans le chapitre 4 qui sortira demain
soir j'espère vraiment de tout coeur que
ce qu'on a réussi à avoir emilie qui est
probablement la femme de sa vie
pour l'heure emilie is the way is the
way